depuis quelques jours TF1 vous a permis
de mieux connaître Liliane Bernadette et
Daniel il s'agit vous l'aurez compris
des épouses de George Marchet de Jacques
Chirac et de François mitteran alors ce
soir avec Jean-Pierre pernaau un
portrait d'anemon
giscardestin un petit événement au
milieu de la campagne électorale celle
qu'on aperçoit toujours derrière son
mari était pour une fois au devant de la
scène
anniversaire à Montpellier le 10 avril
c'était l'anniversaire d'anemon
giscardestin depuis un mois madame
giscardestin accompagne son mari presque
partout discrète mais toujours présente
elle participe activement à la campagne
et assiste à la plupart des meetings
demande à Hoche en passant par Colmar
mais son activité ne s'arrête pas là dès
l'annonce de la candidature de son épou
Anemon a commencé à sillonner la France
elle a visité plus de 50 comités de
soutien expliquant le programme de son
candidat les contacts direct avec les
électeurs tâ difficile dans des régions
qui n'ét pas tout acquis au giscardisme
exemple ici à 9h dans la Nièvre fief de
François mit il se trouve que je suis
persuadé que mon mari est le meilleur
candidat alors trve que c'est
normal jeis
une le jour de pâ une pause un weekend
en famille àut dans le
loch le temps d'offrir un uf en
chocolat de
a les habits du vill et quelques he plus
tard on retrouve avec monquetier au
quartier général de la campagne rue de
marign à
Paris qui est devenue la première dame
de France il y a 7 ans celle dont le
prénom et l'élégance sont aujourd'hui
famili n'a pas hésité à se lancer elle
aussi et très concrètement dans cette
campagne il n'y a aucun trou dans son
emploi du temps jusqu'au 10
mai